[Music]
okay so i got married in november this
is my second marriage okay um we don't
live together why don't you all live
together
because the housing market is still high
here we're just kind of sitting and
waiting i guess you'll get together for
weekend hookups or whatever but like
this isn't a marriage you know what i
mean
[Music]
i want to know what love is
what's up everybody this is dr john
dolone's show we talk about your mental
health your relationships your schools
your education whatever's going on in
your life i don't care we're here to
walk alongside yet and it's a mess out
there and this is a place where we're
gonna hang out and be
rational and we're gonna be calm and
we're gonna try to solve problems by
sitting next to each other and figuring
it out not yelling at one another and
being like you know what yeah this is
not what we do i'm gonna walk alongside
just the greatest mental health podcast
of all time ever and youtube shows the
best show ever
um my mom tells me that actually she
doesn't even tell me that she's big into
like outlander and stuff but if you want
to be on this show call uh give us a
shout 1-844
that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask and i'll point back out dude we are
growing out there we're up to seven out
in the lobby now which is officially
doubles the entire listenership of the
show which is awesome
it's good to see all seven listeners
just y'all like you're just gonna go in
person we're not even gonna do this via
the uh headphones that's awesome so
we'll try this again i i this is the
second run through here for the intro
because i screwed up the phones last
time so i'm going to try again to go to
missoula and talk to erica hey erica
what's up
hi i'm dr johanni how are you
i'm doing all right how are you good
sorry i hung up on you a minute ago
we're still friends right
of course yes
i've i've got a very low number so i
need to preserve all i got so what's up
um
i
need to
know some
other perspective about whether or not i
should
forgive
my husband for
basically cheating on me again
well tell me about it
um he
he had an affair about 10 years ago and
he um
we were able to reconcile it took about
a year and we also had my third child
and um
he i told him if he ever ever cheated on
me again i would leave him for good and
recently he got fired for sexual
harassment at his job
and what happened
he
told me that
he was being fight that he was being
written up
for sexual harassment because he made a
stupid joke to
somebody that's actually our friend
and she got very angry and so she
um she reported him
and this whole time they weren't nobody
was telling me anything about it and
it lasted about a week
and so the day that he was fired he
told me that it was for one one joke
and it
was
it ended up being more than one joke but
um
that wasn't achieving that he had been
that he had
cheated he had
texted a girl
half his age um
and talking about
things
inappropriately like wearing her thighs
as your mouth
and um
i miss what you said
she talked about
he was texting this this girl about
um inappropriate things
like wearing her
thighs earmuffs oh okay gotcha gotcha
like just sexually explicit stuff okay
all right i didn't hear what you said
okay
so
wearing her thighs ear muffs i've nev
i've literally never heard that one
before
um
so
um he gets in trouble at work he's
running his mouth being stupid
and um
you know as well as i do it's rare that
somebody even though with all the
backlash we have these days it's rare
that somebody fires you when it done
right so some some sort of something was
going on there and then as a part of
this you found out the other thing was
going on so what's your what's your big
picture question
um
can i ever trust him again
hmm
what do you think you've been living
with him for a decade or more right how
long have you been married
uh
we've been together for 24 years 24
years been married for
19.
okay
um you tell me
i don't feel like
i can trust him
i feel like
i i try to believe in people and that
they can change and be better so i feel
like if he was to change
change and grow up
i feel like that would be
i would be able to trust him then but
that's it's those are you're making
those are mutually
those are not mutually exclusive
he can grow up
and he can't change
and that doesn't mean you have to be
married to him
he can grow up and he can't change and
he did
a couple of times nuke your marriage
you can choose to stay
and be a part of that healing process
right you see i'm saying there's a bunch
of options and anytime we back ourselves
into a corner and say it's either this
or this we're always going to make a
less than good decision because we feel
forced into a choice and so you've got a
bunch of different options here
the
going back to your original question
ultimately forgiveness is for you
and there's some there's a in the
psychological literature there's some
arguments that go back and forth and in
the clinical therapy space people argue
back and forth i'm of the opinion and
again you can get online and find
different opinions and from brilliant
people right
i'm of the opinion that there is little
to no healing
without forgiveness
because forgiveness is for you it's not
for him forgiveness is you holding this
brick that he placed in your hands a
brick of infidelity a brick of lack of
trust a brick of dishonesty
and forgiveness is you setting that down
and saying i'm not carrying your stuff
anymore i'm letting this go
now we're going to have to deal with the
consequences of this i can't trust you i
don't want to be with you anymore
um
i
bet
there's a gap of 10 years between this
behavior i have to believe there was
other things that went on right whether
it was all electronic or in person who
knows but it's that it's that gnawing i
don't know what comes next right that
keeps you up at night and you got a
quarter of a century with this person
you all made humans together right so
there's something to not just throw away
lightly
so i'll circle back to you and this is
the scary question that i'm pretty sure
you have an answer to
what do you want to do
i honestly don't know i feel like if i
if i
uh
work on this healing with him and stay
with him that i'll be disrespecting
myself
and
here's what i think honestly and i've
had this conversation with so many
people over the years i think you know
i think the consequences of your choice
are scary
is that fair yeah
yeah i don't want my children
to have to go through a divorce and i i
was i had
my parents divorced and it they made it
horrible for us and
i don't want to do that to my children
right
and again you've you've put yourself in
an either or there are divorces where
the adults in the room act like adults
and there is separations that say hey
this has to happen because of
so-and-so's behavior but we're going to
treat each other with dignity and
respect for on behalf of these young
kids right so it's not a either
you have to stay miserable and
disrespected in in in the hostile
uh situat the home life
or the kids have to go through a messy
divorce it's not an either or again okay
it feels like you've made your choice
but the idea of separating moving
getting your own place
dividing the estate all the stuff
downstream
is a lot of stuff it's hard that doesn't
mean it's wrong that means it's hard
right is there an interim space have you
all spent some time apart
well since he was fired from his job he
had to go
work i told him to go work in another
state and
[Laughter]
he was working in another state before
and then um
and then kovit happened and he was home
for
for that and um
it wasn't as much money but he was
we were struggling but um i told him
that was
seemed to be the only option for him to
be able to live
so he's he's gone for three to
three plus weeks okay
um
yeah i was gonna say i've heard of
somebody like you gotta go sleep on the
couch i haven't heard somebody be like
you gotta go sleep in missouri or
something i haven't heard that that's a
new one right you gotta go to michigan
um
here's what i think needs to happen two
things number one
um
you've probably heard me say this on the
show i'll say it again because i think
it's worth repeating
when somebody cheats on you
there's the obvious betrayal
and there's the obvious disorientation
like everything we thought we were
standing on the sidewalk that we walk on
now is
busted up right so that that happens
but the i think the a as
if using the sidewalk metaphor you can
fix that sidewalk you can go get a
contractor who will walk alongside you
and y'all can dig all that concrete up
and it stinks and it's hot and all that
but you can get it done you can clean
that up
but i think the silent killer in
infidelity
is
that you erica no longer trust erica
because in your head you think dude i've
been down this road i should have seen
this coming
how in the world oh my gosh how did i
miss this i'm crazy
and if he's good at what he does he'll
say oh it was one time thing i was just
drinking or i was this thing and you're
making a big deal about it and you start
to feel that you're crazy
and you start to feel that you can't
trust you
and that's when you call a guy just a
rando dude on a podcast and you're like
hey i don't even know how to i don't
even know how to feel you you see what
i'm saying
and so one of the important parts of
healing from infidelity and this is you
get fired from a job and that you're
that you didn't see coming right or a
leader demotes you or gives you a pay
cut that you don't see coming right
these are any type of relational
interactions that are out of the blue
and that fracture the relationship
is you've got to sit down and heal i've
got to learn to re-trust myself and just
because this happened doesn't mean i'm
not trustworthy
i'm going to always look in the mirror
and say did i contribute anything in
this in this relationship am i going to
participate i know that's not pc to say
you know did i participate in this have
i what role did i play here and then i'm
going to be honest with a counselor with
a group of close friends
walking through
i am trustworthy and here's what i think
the next right step is
and so one i think you need to go talk
to a counselor
by yourself and say this is what
happened because my guess is over the
last two decades together
in between the two instances of
infidelity there's been some significant
distance between the two of you is that
fair
um
he worked i mean he worked in another
whole seasons but yeah every time we've
had ever we've ever had any issues or i
felt like we were
um
in danger
i
we've gone and seen counselors or and if
that didn't work i was trying to work on
myself and okay
so you've put the time and the effort in
and it's it's a you're looking at this
as though you failed you screwed
something up
and
i need you to hear me say you didn't
fail okay
three
do you believe me
yes
okay i need you to internalize that you
didn't fail
and if this ends up in divorce you have
options so that it doesn't turn into a
mess that you experienced as a kid
is it going to hurt your children 100
absolutely is it going to be a mess yes
it's gonna be hard yes all those things
are true
um but that doesn't mean it's not the
right thing and
choosing to go get back up on the horse
again and go through the healing process
again and what is this gonna look like
that's not the
necessarily the wrong choice either
i'm afraid that if i do that
that he'll do it again i mean i think
all the evidence suggests that's the
case
right but i'm not gonna sit here on the
phone after talking to you for five
minutes and say you gotta get out of
this relationship i think it's a mess
i definitely think it's a mess
um tell me about your friend
that you said your husband told a dirty
joke to somebody or dirty jokes to
somebody who happened to be a friend who
told on him and ultimately led to his
departure are you all still talking
apparently
she wants she says that she just needed
a
safe space to work and i feel like
she could it's
i feel like she could have come outside
of work and
told me what was going on and i would
have
we could have handled it that way versus
causing a financial
hardship on our family in addition to
the so hear me say that
i i think she did the right thing
and the person who caused the financial
hardship issues in your home is your
husband not her
now
i would expect my friend to come tell me
right so i get that
the like the
the
schoolyard code i get that totally
but it's your husband that put another
woman in an uncomfortable position at
work
and
based on what you've told me i don't
trust that there was one dirty joke that
was told that ultimately led to him
getting fired my guess is there's a
pattern of behavior there
right right and so
her repeatedly having to go to work and
be uncomfortable next to her best
friend's cheating husband who also is
making sexual jokes which often sexual
jokes are fishing expeditions
because if she laughs or she winks or
she tells a funny sexual joke back
now we have this connection and now
right see what i'm saying so it can go
down a road
and
her saying i feel uncomfortable
um or if she'd ever anyway all i had to
say is
you're gonna have to have this is the
second thing you gotta have some adult
conversations
you gotta sit down with him and say
what's the future i need six months by
myself to be separated or i've lost
trust in you
um
at this point i don't feel comfortable
being married to you
or i'm willing to try this thing again
like you all need to get in a room and
go to breakfast somewhere and have some
hard conversations directly across the
table
okay
just saying you go away it's not going
to help and having these conversations
at home in the context of being at home
is going to be
hard because it's that that your home is
charged and the kids are right there in
the next room so get out of the house
y'all go sit somewhere and tell them
we're going to have a hard adult
conversation
and tell them i don't know that i can be
married to you anymore
but also i remember what happened to me
and so if we go down this road of
divorce we're gonna have to be adults on
behalf of these kids
and is that pie in this guy thinking on
my part it might be i just have this
belief that adults can be adults even
when it's hard and i know that there's
millions of people that act like
children all the time it's annoying um
but all the way back to your original
question forgiveness is for you
and so maybe this breakfast that you'll
go to this lunch or dinner y'all go to
you start that by sit by write that down
put it on a brick put a piece of tape on
a brick and write down
cheating
or you cheated and
put that on the table and hand it to
them and say i'm not carrying this
anymore i forgive you
now here's how i feel and here's some of
the consequences of what happened and
we're gonna move forward that way
forgiveness doesn't mean passivity
forgiveness doesn't mean consequences
forgiveness doesn't mean i forget
everything forgiveness just means i'm
not carrying this and that's for you
not for him
don't carry that around
but do go see somebody you got some
healing work to do and you need some
help sifting through the jungle of your
feelings and thoughts right now because
it's a lot
and
last thing i'll tell you i'll remind you
it's not your fault
it's not your fault we'll be right back
[Music]
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe cause you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right cool kids we are what is that
cool kids and kitten who is that was
that cool cats and kittens
was that carol baskin carol baskin yeah
harold's asking dude talk about that
coming out of nowhere
man oh carol b we need to get her on the
show
no we don't we do not all right let's go
to patrick in cleveland what's up
patrick
hey dr john how are you ballin dude 20's
blade's only impala what are you doing
that's good
uh i've been better but i'm glad to talk
to you
that was a good that was a good diss
you're like ah that was good
thanks man
i deserve that all right so what's up
so
i am just at a point like a breaking
point in my life where i feel like i am
just so
overwhelmed i don't even know who i am
anymore like i'm just ready to explode i
just i i don't even know what it's like
to be happy anymore and i just can't
take it anymore so i need some insight
yeah man well thanks for calling um
unpack that a little bit for me
well it's definitely a lot a lot to it
definitely a mixed bag with a lot of
years of of trauma and a lot going on
but to get condense it all i'd say the
last decade of my life i mean i'm 30 now
and the last decade of my life i've just
had to constantly be on
and why i just
well
i'm a chronic people pleaser and i and i
take on way more than i can handle okay
it's because i'm so driven and motivated
to get where i want in life hold on hold
on before we get going i want us to
begin to change your language as you
tell the story is that cool
sure so instead of saying i've had to be
on for the last decade
i want you to change the language to
have chosen to be on for the last decade
yeah
we're gonna start taking ownership of
this okay and that's the first that's
the first line like that's the starting
line to
getting well okay
so you've chosen to
please everybody and to take on a whole
bunch of stuff and to be driven and
ambitious
um what are you running from like what
did somebody tell you that you weren't
gonna make it when you were a kid or you
come from a pretty rough situation like
you're you're running from something
what is it
i definitely am running i've been
sprinting but no you're exactly you're
exactly right i came from a really rough
childhood
my uh i'm the youngest of five boys
divorce family
alcoholics my mom died when i was 22 on
my birthday
i was molested as a kid numerous times
just a lot a broken broken family i had
to constantly
be a therapist to my own mom she
overtook my bedroom i had to sleep in my
dad's room she slept with a knife
it's just a lock yeah
and and what do you do for a living now
well um i'm a musician i play in three
different bands and
i am in a sales job and it's finally
like a big boy job you know i've always
taken jobs in my 20s where it was like
okay i didn't really care if i didn't
work there anymore but
being 30 i figured it's time to take on
a career because i wasn't sure where my
music was going and i was getting to
this point where i was getting really
discouraged and now that i've taken on
this career it's becoming harder to
balance my music
because this is a lot more demanding of
a job and it's it's you know forced me
to travel for work and and it's really
affecting my my job i'm almost feeling
like i'm going to lose my job because
i'm so stressed right
um what is the um what is the
what does the music give you
well the music is my true passion and
i've always told people like
it's almost a curse to find your true
passion because what you when you can't
guarantee it's going to happen or
anything's going to come of it it's like
you can't just go to college and get
your degree and just be like okay i've
made it it's like all a gamble yeah here
let me back up so here's the thing about
passion
we're passionate about what we're good
at and we're good at what we practice
and most of us practice what we're made
to practice when we're younger or that
we developed the discipline and skill to
practice when we're older
and my guess is you've been playing
music a long time and i grew up playing
in bands i still play in bands i love it
it makes me
so joyful there's nothing funnier than
than playing with a group of people
especially in front of a big audience
that enjoys what you're doing
that's something you like doing but
you're getting something from that not
just fulfilling your passion because you
like connecting with people is my guess
or you like making other people feel at
ease and that's the same thing that kept
you alive as a kid
and now that same defense mechanism has
become the way you operate in the world
and it's exhausting because your body is
still in fight or flight
see what i'm saying you can get
passionate about sales as you practice
it and get better at it and better at it
and especially if you're selling
something you believe in and you sit
down across a table from somebody or a
corporation you say i can make y'all's
lives better
with this product
dude that connection you'll get good at
that and you'll become passionate about
it i've never been on the radio ever
until two and a half years ago
and now i'm super passionate about it i
love it but i've been practicing like
crazy and i do it all day every day and
early in the morning and you know what i
mean so you'll get passion from other
things
they're getting something from music and
it's either a connection that you
finally feel like you belong with a
group of men and women that you play
with or in front of an audience or
you're talented i don't know what the
thing is you're getting
but here's the thing that thing that
you're getting is also killing you and
at some point you're going to have to
pick one band
and let the other ones go
you're gonna have to say i i do this on
the side this is a thing that i love to
do
but i'm gonna work really hard to become
really good at sales so that i can eat
you see what i'm saying or
blow it all and say forget it i'm going
to ride or die on this thing like i mean
if you want to be a great musician go be
a great musician and
just know that you know most musicians
don't make it and that's fine um you
don't have to be rich and wealthy to
have a good life but you got to make
that decision and this is the big thing
exhale
and so let me tell you this
i don't think you're addicted to people
pleasing
i think you're trying to
survive and pleasing people when you
were young kept you
from maybe not getting molested this
time
or maybe not getting your head kicked in
by one of your older brothers
people pleasing as a kid
you were told kept mom from killing
herself
that's not an addiction to people
pleasing that is an addiction to
surviving
okay yeah
and that same thing that kept you alive
as a kid is now wearing you out
and so yes for whatever it's worth man
i'm just some stranger on the internets
but i'm giving you permission to stop
your life's worth more than this right
yeah
and what you don't have is you don't
have a picture of what peace looks like
do you
not at all yeah so you're running as
fast as you can solving accomplishing
playing being good at these things so
that people will look at you and go that
guy's got it together i'm gonna tell you
you're gonna end up a salesman who's
really good i think every kid should
either do theater or and or music every
single child in the world because if you
can master a stage you can do anything
if you can be good in front of people
whether it's six people or 106 people or
a thousand people you can do anything
you're going to be a great salesman
because you know how to connect with an
audience
and you're going to get a million
dollars and you're going to pay off your
house and you're going to have a new
tesla and you're gonna be married
and you're gonna find yourself asking
your kid to move out of his room so you
can go sleep in his bed
because those things won't heal you you
know what i mean
yeah
they're cool mile markers on a sprint
but they are not going to heal you and
dude i want to pay my house off and i
want a nice tesla and i want you know i
mean i want those things but i know that
those things aren't going to solve me
right
and the question i have for you is
do you want to stop
i don't want to stop
pursuing my dreams of music i've not
given up the fact that i could maybe
make it
really really far and i've already
achieved a good level of success and i
think that's where i struggle is i don't
i can't come to grips with the idea of
possibly never making it whatever that
means because you've put making it what
exactly that's a great point by the way
making it like what who that bar moves
every time you get to wherever you think
you're going to go right every time you
sell out the theater they're like well
what about this place and every time you
sell the club then it's like are you
going to move sell out this place and so
that line moves
but you think that you are going to feel
a certain way when you get to a place
and i'm telling you right now that place
does not exist
you are spot on is that fair
it is because i've achieved a lot of
these different things and every time i
get them i go okay what's next a friend
of mine tells a great story he was a
guitar player for a famous songwriter
and he was walking onto carnegie hall he
was waiting in the wings
and he had his phone he's put his phone
away and he got a ding and he checked
his cell phone balance i mean his bank
balance on a cell phone and it was
negative he was in the red let him know
they're just been overdraft and he put
it in his pocket as he walked out to
play in carnegie hall in new york
and it was like i made it and i'm broke
you know what i mean like there is no or
you get off stage like that was awesome
and then you get back on the same stupid
bus and go to the next town you know
what i mean you know that
yeah and you'll make an incredible sale
and you'll feel so good and you'll go to
dinner and you'll feel good and you wake
up the next morning then you got to go
to the gym again
and then you got to be nice to your wife
and your kids again and then you got to
start the making new cold calls right
the whole thing just starts over again
and for some people that fries them out
for me i've learned to love that about
life
i love it
because my value isn't found there
and nobody may have ever told you this
but i need you to hear me say patrick
you are worth laying down in bed at
night just going to sleep
and you're worth loving somebody and not
worrying about if they're going to
molest you or take something from you
yeah and you're worth loving somebody
all in and not worrying about if they're
going to take their life and die by
suicide
you know what i mean and i know you
don't believe me i know you don't
believe me and it's you're fair not to
believe me your body's like okay that's
cute brother you haven't lived what i've
lived and you're right
um i share more of your story than you
know but what i'll tell you is this
there is healing on the other side of
this if you want it
but here's what that looks like okay and
this is hard you're gonna have to decide
to identify the things that kept you
alive as a kid that are now hurting you
as an adult
obsession with people pleasing trying to
do too many things saying yes to
everything
letting one thing that was really
important to you
um dialing it back a bit so that you can
be successful in something else
those things
you've got to identify them and choose
to intentionally set them down
and it's going to feel like taking off
articles of clothing in a public
intersection
you're going to feel completely exposed
and that's where the healing begins
yeah it's almost like if i am less
active on social media and engaging with
my fans i feel like i'm i'm backtracking
you know yes yes i'm trying to stop that
listen patrick it's a lie
it's a lie
all burnout is it's a real thing it is a
physiological thing it's not just i'm
tired it's
you're experiencing it it's when your
body says we have been fighting and
fleeing
for too long
we're out
i'm out
i've tried to get your attention with
anxiety i've tried to get your attention
with depression i've tried to get your
attention with
chaos i've tried i've tried i'm out i'm
just done
okay so your body just says screw you
i'm going home i'm taking my ball and
i'm going home
and so here's what you've got to promise
me
number one you'll reach out and decide
for the first time in your life i'm
gonna get healing i'm gonna go call a
professional and that's what you need
you gotta have counseling i had to have
it people i love have to have it you're
there okay you need to go talk to a
professional and say i'm worth this
you also have to pick one of these three
bands and say i'm gonna sit this one out
i've got too much on my plate
are you willing to do that
100 which band
that's the struggle is which band i
choose because both of them are very
well all of them are popular and
demanding and it's just hard just hard
to pick
and then they're going to find somebody
else that plays guitar or bass or drums
and then they're going to go on about
their day
and you are too and you're going to feel
that twinge of i wish i was there but
then we're going to move on you know
what i mean and here's the thing if that
band goes on and becomes pearl jam
you know what you are alive
yeah because you won't be on the
trajectory you're on
yeah okay sure
so um a couple of real quick things okay
and then i'll let you go
okay do i have your commitment to um
getting well
like i want this to be different
yes absolutely okay so you're gonna call
a professional counselor you're gonna
make that call today
i've actually already been trying to see
one and she's
understanding me she's not giving me a
lot of skills sets yet but okay
on to the next thing
find somebody that you connect with and
if you don't connect in that first
session say thank you so so much i'm
grateful for you you're gonna make
another appointment um no thank you i
appreciate your time
right okay but i want you to go in and
say i've got some very serious childhood
traumas
i've got some very serious pathologies
that i deal with
sexual abuse physical abuse all sorts of
stuff and i'm ready to
heal i want to use that type of language
when you take that type of ownership
okay
the second thing is is you have to get a
group of men in your life that you can
do life with just hang out
that could be your band
but often band becomes a performance and
it be literally and it becomes a uh
status thing
you need a group of guys you can prop
your feet up with and say i'm not doing
okay today
and they're not gonna go well what about
the band bro
you don't need that you need a friend
that's a banker and like one that mows
lawns you know what i mean
right it does different things um are
you married now
i'm not okay are you interested in that
are you just ready to chill
well i've been with a girl now for four
years and that was another thing that's
a side that i would like to get your
interest or excuse me your intellect
from but i know our time is limited but
she's pressuring me to get married and
i'm just not in the position where i'm
ready mentally that's cool i mean four
years is a long time that's fair for her
and that's fair for you right um it is
let's set up another call for that one
so we'll go down that rabbit hole
another one here's the third thing i
want you to commit to
will you commit to making exercise and
sleep and eating a little bit better a
priority
and that i currently do so i'm there
good yep but you start in that order
sleep first everything comes after sleep
if i have to skip a workout i'm gonna
skip a workout so i can get sleep
i'm gonna miss that i still haven't seen
the new top gun movie i haven't seen
several movies that are out because
sleep is still the priority i haven't
had the time okay
yeah i'm gonna make those priorities i'm
gonna miss this gig because of sleep or
i had this gig so i'm gonna have to
sleep anyway you know what i mean make
those things a priority so that your
body has a chance to do the healing that
it needs to do cool
absolutely so let me tell you this
on the other side of this
fast forward two and a half years and
you're engaged
and if not tied up
okay
i said that in a real negative way
you're married and not tied up like your
life is good
the choices you make right now to decide
to be well
there is light at the end of this tunnel
if you want to make that journey and
it's gonna suck
it will not be fun and it will be worth
every single step because on the back
end you're gonna be able to laugh
you're not gonna have to put your back
into a corn like every time you walk
into a restaurant put your back up
against the wall so you can see the
whole restaurant
you're gonna be able to not get raged
out angry when somebody cut you off
you're gonna be able to lay your head
down and just fall asleep
in the arms of somebody that you love
and not worry about what's gonna happen
there's this piece brother does that
make sense
it makes perfect sense do you want that
i want it more than anything okay i'm
tired right here i got i got you all
right so we're gonna make that call
today and find another therapist and
hang on the line here i'm gonna give you
a copy of own your past change your
future it's my treat to you um read it
give it to your girlfriend you all read
it together
and um
begin this journey moving forward i'm
really proud of you for just saying
enough's enough is enough i got to do
something different i've been there
millions of people been there and the
first step is one of bravery so good for
you brother good for you you can do it
you can do it and i'll walk with you
every step of the way give me a shout
back let's talk about this girlfriend of
yours too we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video
phone even live chat sessions with your
therapist you don't even have to see
anyone on a camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month so decide to invest in
yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right let's go
dunamas let's go to jill in cedar city
utah
what's up jill
hi doctor john i'm so honored to be
speaking with you i am more honored to
be talking to you what's up
i'm a little nervous um i appreciated
that last call bye to sing in a band so
i can relate to a lot of that thank you
you got it thank you so much so what's
up um my question is how do i show up
for my kids and my husband through this
transition phase that we're in and not
get exhausted
um so i guess you want a little back
story um i could just start throwing
answers at you
it'll probably be incredible but yes
some more contacts would be helpful
okay so i got married in november this
is my second marriage okay um we don't
live together thank you
we live 30 minutes apart
um so half the time i'm home raising my
kids doing all that stuff why don't
y'all live together
um because the housing market is still
high here we're just kind of sitting and
waiting
um
well it's also because i have
five kids and their whole lives are
right here and they have to go to school
here
and he's got a ranch where he's at so
we're just not sure how to meet in the
middle
but there really is nothing nothing
coming up
for us um
so
you get that you've put yourself in a
pretty tough position to be successful
right
yeah i'm working three jobs at home
to try and make ends meet where i'm at
and i do enjoy i do enjoy those things
is your husband not
like at some point he has to decide
you all have to decide
are we gonna move these five kids to the
ranch
and we're gonna do this life thing
together
or he's gonna get somebody to take care
of his ranch and he's gonna move into
your place y'all's place
or
you're going to sell both things and
move to texas i don't know i don't care
what you all are doing
but you got married and you just kept
living each other's independent lives i
guess you'll get together for weekend
hookups or whatever but like this isn't
a marriage you know what i mean no yeah
it doesn't feel like to marriage no well
i mean it just set out of the gate
without being a marriage y'all wouldn't
got a certificate and had a ceremony but
like y'all aren't married
like his money is your money and your
money is his money and his kids are your
kids i mean y'all learn this thing
together
right yeah that's how it feels
it is
so what's the what's the holdup
um i did offer to move there and travel
with my kids back and forth
but he wanted to keep one of his
bedrooms for his children for his son to
come home when he wanted to come home
and house is really small i'm in a
rental
he owns his place
jail joe joe joe joe
i
i'm assuming that no one's told you what
i'm about to tell you and you know if
you've listened to this show more than
once that i will never lie to you okay
um
but this isn't gonna work
you don't marry somebody and let them
rent a house in another city
so that you can have an extra spare room
for your kids whenever they show up what
a mess
yeah the other thing that's making this
really hard is he has um anxiety and
depression that i just that that's
trying to show up for him that is all i
could care less about that right now
that isn't the other problem
you all have created a completely
disconnected existence from one another
and you're calling each other husband
and wife you are no more married than me
and i was gonna say me and kelly but me
and kelly are more married than y'all
two are
right she's like within 10 feet of me i
see her every single day for hours on
end god help us all and i'm just kidding
she's but you know see what i'm saying
just your language
he doesn't want me in his house it's
y'all's house
did you send a prenup that
that you don't that the ranch you have
nothing to do with ranch
um i'm not on
no and i'm not on any of the financial
things i know but you're his wife
if he died today you're the wife it goes
to you yeah it goes to his ex-wife his
life insurance and stuff
what
um that was in his divorce
that until his last child support
payment
um his life insurance goes to his
ex-wife
and
i think the state would take his his
home and land and stuff at this point so
i don't we've talked about it several
times he hasn't really given me an
answer
okay okay listen
i am very
lazy
i'm real big on somebody called earlier
in this show and asked me you know their
husband had cheated on him a couple of
times and asked me and i i my answer to
them was what do you think
so here's what i'm telling you i'm not
telling you what do you think
i'm telling you you deserve more than
this
you all deserve more than this
and y'all are playing married
in a tragic way your kids are getting a
picture of this is what marriage looks
like
this is how a man takes care of his life
she works three jobs and rents a house
in another city because i want to keep
an empty bedroom
i mean it's non the whole thing is
insane right
and i don't know what this dude's trying
to pull off but
um
i have a real real direct heart wait
what happens if he dies
i guess you go on renting a house
working three jobs right you're living a
life
you are living the life that we i tell
people to get life insurance to avoid
you know what i mean
how long have you all been married in
november
yeah
so here if i'm you
i'm only going to tell you if i'm you
i would say hey we need to we need to
talk
and i'll even drive out to your ranch
and by the way i'd start changing that
language real quick to our ranch
hours
to our rental home
to our kids
this you and my stuff
your marriage will never it will never
work because it's our stuff and my stuff
and your stuff
this is
ours
we're in this thing together
that fine he's got a life insurance
policy for his ex-wife through some
decree fine he's gonna have to get one
on you
oh i started that process myself no no
he's got to participate
not participate he's got to lead the
effort
okay to love his new wife enough to take
care of her if he dies
so that's a small price to pay
you'll have to have a three-month plan
to unify your families
and at some point you may have to look
at him and say is this ranch more
important your marriage to me because if
it is i need to know
because then i got to make other plans
if you're keeping this ranch up
and it might be i mean it might be an
incredible ranch i'm all about ranches
i'm from texas i love me a good ranch i
would love to have one one day
um it will never be more important than
my wife
i'm never gonna i can't even wrap my
head around my wife living 45 minutes
away
with five kids renting a house i mean it
sounds preposterous you know what i'm
saying and here's what happens this
stuff happens step by step quietly and
quietly and you start to think this is
normal
and so hear me say joe you're not crazy
this is nuts
do you feel isolated out on an island by
yourself
yeah
yeah i feel you should cause you all you
are
and i here's what i hate i hate that
this might end up in a really messy
situation
i do
i hate you having to sit down and say do
you love this ranch more than me
because i can't do marriage we're just
gonna be married and just live in other
towns indefinitely
while your kids do whatever and my five
kids like that's just how it's gonna
work man you gotta have a plan to come
together
and he and he might say no
okay so be ready for the
but you all need to get in a room and
you need to write down really quick what
you need you need life insurance you
need to live with your husband you need
to have your husband involved in your
five kids lives you'll need to come up
with a plan for working with exes you
all need to dig all that go through all
that stuff
and not just hook up on weekends
is that fair is that fair
yeah that's fair i feel like i'm getting
on to you but i'm not trying to get on
to you i'm just trying to i'm trying to
like just shake the snow globe a little
bit and let you see how bonkers this is
yeah it feels feels bonkers okay because
it is so if nothing if nothing else you
called uh yahoo with a podcast and a
youtube show to tell you that yes you
are correct this is bonkers
this is mrs bonkers now as a part of
healing
your husband may have to deal with his
anxiety and his depression 100
that's done with connection not hiding
on a range
he may have to deal with his anxiety and
depression that's something he's got to
decide as as a person
living in the world i want to heal from
this this is not something that you can
just quote unquote manage or have to
quote unquote deal with that's not how
he's going to heal
okay he's got to decide i want to be a
part of this and then you can be a part
of his healing plan but it's going to
have to be something he decides he wants
to heal from
so when he's around my kids he's he's
very
impatient
i don't want to put him down because he
plays with him and he's super sweet
but he gets really impatient really
quickly and very critical
yes yes yes
his kids were kind of taken from him and
don't have much to do with them and so i
think it triggers him to be around my
kids
so here's the deal i'm not letting
anybody
who is going to be triggered around my
children around my children
and i realize this puts you in a strange
pickle because you decided to marry this
guy
but i'm not putting somebody around my
kids it's not safe to be around my kids
even if it's my new uh new husband
and so we're gonna have a conversation
you and him about here's what it looks
like when you're with our kids you're
patient and you're kind and you're
gentle and you're fun
and we will slowly lean into
accountability as we blend these
families together
but i'll take the chief
the lion's share of the discipline as we
transition this thing and slowly move it
as the kids come to trust you and love
you and that only comes through presence
and connectivity
day in day out relationship relationship
relationship
it's not this random dude who shows up
every week to hook up with their mom and
then goes back to his ranch
man what a mess
my heart's broken for you jill i'm sorry
um there's only hard conversations ahead
my hope is that you sit down and say you
have a list of your needs written out
i got to be safe i've got to be with you
i've got to live in the same house as
you with these five kids i've got to
have these things this is what a
marriage is ours
i've got to be on the deed to the house
that we're going to share together in
case you die so i have a place to live
so they don't ship it all off to your
ex-wife i'm your new wife
i'm first
i'm first i'm first i'm first cause i'm
your wife
and we're gonna start there and my hope
is he goes oh thank god
will you walk with me as we untangle all
this yes i will i'm all in so i married
you
but you gotta know this conversation is
gonna be a risk
because you might say i'm not doing all
that
it's too much of a mess let's come back
in a year and whatever and i would tell
them
well i'm not going to tell you that
i'll tell you i wouldn't wait a year
that's what i'm telling you
because i married you a year ago
i'm so sorry jill we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward
there is no good app to help adults find
friendships but this book can help go to
johndaloni.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
man those are heavy
listen you are worth more than the life
you're living
seek joy seek laughter
seek connection with people and do not
settle for less than being loved
so wrap up today's show man um
andrew back there on the youtubes
came up with this song man from the one
and only journey and it's not don't stop
not that one it's faithfully and it goes
like this
highway run into the midnight sun and
the wheels go round and round now
kelly's dancing back there you're on my
mind restless heart sleep alone tonight
sending all my love along the wire they
say that the road ain't no place to
start a family right down the line it's
been you and me and loving a music man
ain't always what it's supposed to be a
girl you stand by me i'm forever yours
faithfully
i love it we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode hey
hey i haven't got a good hay in a long
time
so what's up my daughter
i think i feel like she basically has
the life that i want oh
all right so
uh i just gotta stop you that's
literally my favorite when somebody's
like all right so uh i always know it's
going to be good next i found out
later on that she in fact
had a sexually transmitted disease you
know at that point i had it as well i
just don't know what to do i mean it's
been seven years i haven't had any
relationships since then
i think i'm broken i don't really love
my newest child you're not broken